(crowd cheering) - All right,
let's get ya something that's trending
in the social media world, sure
to bring you a little bliss.
This is what I'm liking.
(uplifting music)
A female CEO is working hard
to help little girls dream big,
and she's inspiring them
through a giant Dallas exhibit
featuring more than 120
life-size statues of real women
working in the field of STEM.
It's part of a brilliant
initiative called If Then.
Let's say hi to Nicole
Small, who's standing
in the middle of the exhibit now.
(crowd applause) She watches our show
on NBC 5 Dallas-Fort Worth
at two. What's up Fort Worth?
Hey what's up?
This is amazing. So please tell us more
about the If Then initiative.
- Hi Kelly.
We are so happy to be coming
to you here from Dallas.
I'm Nicole Small, Lyda
Hill Philanthropies,
and we are thrilled to
tell you more about the
If Then movement that was
started a couple of years ago,
because we believe if you
can see it, you can be it.
And we know, like you,
you've got a daughter,
I've got a daughter, lots
of people watching today
have daughters. And we know
that if we show little girls
incredible role models,
doing amazing things,
that those little girls too
will know that they can grow up
and change the world. And that's
what If Then is all about.
And while we were
developing this initiative,
we were doing TikTok channels
and TV shows and fixing
museum walls. We came
across an amazing statistic.
We did not know, and I
don't know if you do,
but we didn't know that
there are only six statues
of women in the top 10 cities in the US.
So, you know, like you were from Texas
and we decided we were
going to go big or go home.
- Yes.
- So instead of just fixing it by a few,
we decided to 3D scan
120 amazing STEM women,
which is what you're seeing behind me.
And one of those amazing
scientists is literally standing
right next to me. This
is Dr. Danielle Twum.
Some of you might recognize her,
Kelly cause she was on
your show not too long ago.
She's a cancer biologist and
she is going to change how we
deal with cancer for
generations. She's incredible.
And also behind me is Victoria.
She is a climate scientist.
We all know that that's a really
important issue right now.
She's also a National Geographic explorer.
And standing next to her is Kristen,
Kristen Lear is a bat conservationist.
And they are just a few of
the incredible, amazing women
that are doing things to
change our world every day.
- Absolutely. (crowd cheering)
And I'm just saying,
they are all orange, so
if you were going to have a
theme song, This Girl is on Fire
would be appropriate. Is all I'm saying.
I think that would be a great song to play
while you're out there.
You can catch the exhibit
- Totally.
- October 24th at North
Park Center in Dallas.
Thank you so much, Nicole. I'm
liking your posts right now,
and that's not all our season
long partner Pilot Pen,
the go-to pen of the Kelly
Clarkson show wants to honor
ultimate overachievers just
like you ma'am so they will be
using their G2 gelling pen to
write the If Then initiative,
a check for a thousand
dollars. How does that sound?
- [Nicole] Wow that's awesome!
- [Kelly] Aw, thank you so much.